bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré une nouvelle fois à la guerre
en Ukraine avec un document exclusif
pour France 24 un reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux James André et Maïssa
hawaïad qui ont passé plusieurs semaines
à baroute la ville du Dombas au cœur des
combats sanglants barmouth qui se trouve
en face de soleda un village en proie
lui aussi à des combats acharnés les
forces ukrainiennes feront tout le
nécessaire pour défendre barthout et
soledar à affirmé Vladimir Zelinski
alors pourquoi ces deux villes
sont-elles devenues le symbole tragique
de la guerre en Ukraine comment survivre
à barmouth en quoi ces combats
révèle-t-il aussi les rivalités au sein
du pouvoir russe entre Prigogine chef de
Wagner le Miss de la défense Sergueï
chouï et Vladimir Poutine mais pas en
parler j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés James André qui est avec nous vous
revenez tout juste de barmoud bonsoir
James on va regarder ensemble justement
votre reportage réalisé avec Mélissa
hawad survivre à barmouth en face de
vous Elena Volochine bonsoir Elena
bonsoir ancienne correspondante en
Russie on vous retrouve dans la
chronique vue de Russie ça sera demain
et c'est tous les vendredis à 18h40
merci d'être avec nous le général
Dominique trinquant était avec nous
bonsoir expert militaire ancien chef de
la mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU et bienvenue à vous James James
André on va regarder tout de suite votre
reportage réalisé donc avec Maïssa Awad
survivre à barmouth
nous entrons d'embarmouth fin décembre
2022 cette ville est le front le plus
actif et le plus violent de la guerre en
Ukraine
la cité coupée en deux par la rivière
barmouka
les Ukrainiens tiennent fermement
l'Ouest
à l'est les rues sont réussi à entrer
dans les faubourgs et l'infanterie
combat à l'arme légère dans les rues les
deux camps ont installé des positions
d'artillerie aux abords de la ville
qu'il pilote nuit et jour
ces soldats Ukrainiens reviennent du
front situé à quelques centaines de
mètres
c'est secret
nous les avons un peu repoussés ça se
passe bien
chaque bataille est une tragédie un mort
c'est la vie d'une personne son avenir
l'avenir de sa famille
ce bâtiment sert de points d'extraction
pour les soldats blessés
ils sont très près 200 300 mètres
maximum
ils veulent prendre la ville à cause des
routes c'est une ville importante pour
eux s'il la prennent ils pourront lancer
la sauce sur sloviande qui est cramator
on ne peut pas les laisser faire
après des mois vivre sous les obus les
civils semblent insensibles à ce qui se
passe autour de
les gens passent ici tous les jours ils
n'ont pas peur ils sont moquent
pour eux la situation est devenue
normale
quitter cette zone s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce que vous faites ici ça tire de
partout
d'une ville de 70000 habitants avant la
guerre baroud s'est transformé en champ
de bataille
il n'y a plus d'eau plus d'électricité
plus de gaz plus de réseau téléphonique
un Nikola et leurs trois enfants se
pressent vers l'un des points d'aide
humanitaire de la ville
on vient ici utiliser le wifi pour
joindre ses proches charger son
téléphone se réchauffer et trouver un
peu de chaleur humaine
nous avons dû éteindre l'incendie tout
seul avec mon mari
mon école a été détruite j'étudie à
l'école numéro 5
si vous voulez évacuer je peux vous
proposer une maison c'est un bel endroit
les propriétaires la laisse en entier je
peux appeler maintenant c'est vraiment
très bien idéal pour les enfants
généreuses qui sont prêtes à nous aider
mais plus tard ils vont se retrouver
dans la même situation que nous et après
c'est eux qui auront besoin d'aide pour
l'instant les combats sont ici mais ça
peut s'étendre là-bas aussi
[Musique]
le volontaire n'a pas réussi à
convaincre Anna et sa famille de partir
les gens ont vécu dans des sous-sols
tout ce qu'ils avaient c'était la radio
russe
ils ont passé beaucoup de temps sans
accès à l'information on leur a dit que
les maris seraient enroulés de force
dans l'armée ou emprisonnée on leur a
dit un tas de choses
plus de 90% de la population de barmut à
fuy la vie est dure pour ceux qui
restent et certains finissent par
craquer comme Angelina
c'est horrible horrible il nous tire
dessus en se promène en se demandant
quand ça va tomber on vit chaque jour
comme si c'était le dernier c'était
effrayant l'atmosphère est oppressante
psychologiquement je veux partir parce
que je ne peux plus rien faire ici
partir pour me laver tout simplement
désolé de dire ça
l'appartement dans lequel Angelina
vivait a été frappée par un obus il y a
trois jours
[Musique]
les fenêtres de notre appartement
celles-ci c'est la cuisine là c'est la
chambre nous dormions il y avait un
grand lit
maintenant il y a des éclats de verre
partout et les cloisons ce sont
complètement effondrées
[Musique]
de choc m'a frappé sur le côté droit je
bois tes
un tir qui a décidé Angelina et Maxime
son compagnon a évacué barmut
la jeune femme avait déjà dû quitter
l'appartement de sa famille 6 semaines
plus tôt là
le bâtiment s'est effondré après une
frappe une partie des habitants s'est
retrouvée coincé dans le sous-sol et son
mort par chance la famille d'Angelina
était absente ce jour-là
des gens sont morts ici coincés sous les
décombres on a sorti des corps il y a
même un pompier qui est mort
excusez-moi c'est dur j'ai envie de
pleurer
presque toute ma famille est partie et
moi aussi je veux être évacué mais mon
père veut rester s'il part ce sera pour
la Russie on n'est pas d'accord moi je
suis une patriote dans ma famille on est
vite ce sujet
dans cette région russophone la guerre a
déchiré les familles entre prorus et
pro-uréiens
Angelina nous a affirmé que son père est
un homme très pieux ce dimanche nous
nous rendons à l'église orthodoxe
affilié au patriarcat russe pour tenter
de le rencontrer
[Musique]
la messe est célébrée dans la crypte à
la bougie
[Musique]
Alexander le père d'Angelina est bien là
venu communier accompagné de deux de ses
fils
[Musique]
Alexander accepte de nous accueillir
chez lui
la maison est au beau milieu du champ de
bataille
notre fenêtre éclaté
on a eu de la chance on a vraiment eu de
la chance
à tous la plupart des éclats ont volé
par ici
on a eu de la chance que l'explosion
part de ce côté
Alexander et ses fils se sont organisés
pour survivre sous les obus
maintenant on est plus ou moins habitués
mais au début on ne pouvait pas dormir
c'était effrayant la maison tremblait
tout le sol bougeait comme de la gelée
vraiment de la gelée
la guerre avec la telle la famille en
trois la femme d'Alexander est partie
avec leur petit-fils se mettre à l'abri
en Russie
Angelina veut rejoindre son autre frère
pro ukrainien vers l'ouest Alexander lui
reste ici avec ses deux autres fils
pour moi l'Ukraine enfin si vous voulez
l'appeler Ukraine est un seul et même
pays avec la Russie et la Biélorussie
c'est en même peuple c'est un arbre avec
différentes branches mais avec les mêmes
racines
ça me fait mal angelina est mon point
faible
je pense qu'elle ne veut plus nous voir
personne ne l'a forcé à partir c'était
ça décision personne ne l'a jeté dehors
elle n'aime pas notre mode de vie elle
veut la liberté la liberté dans le
mauvais sens du terme
[Applaudissements]
en ville les soldats ukrainiens ont
fortifié leur position
ils se sont littéralement enterrés
creusant des tranchées en plein
centre-ville
si tu veux vivre tu creuses plus tu
creuses profond plus tu as une chance de
survivre
les tranchées viennent d'être creusés
nous on fait les finitions nous avons
créé des meurtrières juste au cas où il
viendrait ramper vers nous histoire
d'avoir de bonnes positions de tir
dans l'est de la ville les combats font
rage
les Ukrainiens disent avoir réussi à
reprendre quelques pâtés de maison
[Musique]
repoussant les assauts des soldats
russes et des mercenaires du groupe
paramilitaire Wagner
ou avoir le cerveau complètement lavé il
n'abandonne jamais
ils sont inarrêtables c'est horrible on
dirait de vrais orques
la situation est compliquée nous les
éliminons mais ils reviennent encore et
encore comme des cafards
nous avons beaucoup de pertes beaucoup
de blessés
l'armée ukrainienne ne communique pas
sur ses pertes
mais les ambulances évacuent jour et
nuit les soldats blessés vers les
hôpitaux militaires de la région
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici on nous dit recevoir une centaine de
soldats blessés par jour
voilà qu'est-ce que je peux dire je vais
bien
mais à part ça ça va bien
tout le monde s'est planqué dans les
tranchées j'ai senti une vive douleur
j'ai compris que je m'étais pris un
éclat
j'ai bougé mes doigts il bougeait mais
j'ai compris que mes os étaient cassés
ça faisait un bruit de craquement
[Musique]
les combats les plus durs sont à
backmouth c'est l'enfer l'enfer
le lendemain matin c'est l'heure du
départ pour Angelina et Maxime
nous les retrouvons dans un sous-sol où
ils ont préparé leurs bagages
je suis heureux de quitter le feu de
cette zone de guerre mais je suis triste
d'abandonner ma ville je pense que je
reviendrai un jour
des volontaires conduisent ces bus qui
ramassent les civils près des lignes de
front pour les évacuer gratuitement vers
des zones sur
aujourd'hui Angelina et Maxime sont les
seuls passagers
d'autres fois c'est 15 ça dépend le
problème c'est qu'il n'y a plus de
réseau téléphonique donc on passe chaque
jour à la même heure et on prend aussi
les gens qui arrivent à nous joindre
[Musique]
hier j'ai pleuré c'est vraiment dur je
n'ai aucune envie de partir mais il n'y
a pas de travail pas d'argent on a froid
et fins tout le temps j'ai envie de
vivre
prochaine arrêt la grande ville de ni
pro 260 km à l'ouest
là-bas Angelina et Maxime devront se
rebâtir une vie en attendant que la paix
revienne à parmoute
à la sortie de la ville un nouvel obus
vient de tomber l'université est en
flamme
[Musique]
à survivrapage que vous pouvez retrouver
sur notre site internet aussi
www.franc24.com James beaucoup
d'émotions en fait dans ce reportage
très dur d'abord on entend des
bombardements en permanence enfin il n'y
a pas un moment où il n'y a pas
effectivement un obus qui tombe et puis
il y a ces deux aspects à la fois le
côté population civile cette famille est
totalement déchirée par le conflit et
puis le front sur la population civile
on se demande quand même pourquoi vous
dites dans votre portage qu'il ne reste
que 10% des gens qui restent mais
pourquoi reste-t-il alors il y a plein
de raisons différentes parce qu'on a
parlé à plein de gens bon là on a mis
une famille qui refuse en fait alors
qu'on est là qu'on leur propose de
partir avec trois enfants et qui
décident de rester il y a des gens qui
ont peur que leur appartement soit payé
ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez classique et qui surveille aussi
les appartements de de leurs voisins on
a rencontré une famille comme ça qui
disait non surveille tous les
appartements des voisins etc mais on
reste on reste parce qu'on a un petit
salaire parce qu'on a peur de se
retrouver à la une fois qu'on sera tombé
en panne d'aide humanitaire c'est-à-dire
beaucoup de gens nous ont dit oui
d'accord on va donner un appartement
pendant une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines mais après moi je gagne 2000
Grigny par mois une fois que j'ai pu
d'aide comment ça se termine dans la rue
moi je veux pas finir à la rue donc ces
gens-là disent je préfère rester et
après vous avez les gens qui restent
parce qu'ils ont des personnes âgées par
exemple une famille
un truc qui est aussi assez surprenant
c'est qu'en fait les grandes ONG pour le
coup par contre c'est devenu trop
violent ils sont sortis donc vous n'avez
plus les grandes ONG internationales qui
continuent à envoyer de l'aide mais
qu'il envoie via des volontaires qui eux
restent en ville et qui continuent à
aider les gens et qui vous disent bah
écoutez moi si je suis pas là qui va
distribuer ses colis alimentaires à ces
gens comment ils vont s'en sortir et
puis il y a quand même un phénomène
aussi c'est que vous avez des gens qui
sont soit on va dire des politisés c'est
à dire qu'il reste en se disant
j'attends la paix que ce soit les Russes
les ukrainiens et ben tous les risques
moi je reste et puis vous en avez aussi
qui sont effectivement sympathisants aux
prunus et qui se disent et bien moi je
reste j'attends les Russes vont prendre
la ville et ensuite tout ira très bien
on a vu justement cette famille déchirée
entre ce père donc prorus cette séquence
effectivement on le voit pendant
l'office
orthodoxe alors qu'on sait de l'Église
russe qui est totalement partisane pour
la meilleure poutine et puis cette fille
donc qui part avec son petit ami ça
arrive en fait c'est arrivé souvent que
ces familles soient déchirées parce que
certaines épousaient les la propagande
ne Vladimir Poutine et d'autres au
contraire voulaient ce qu'il disait elle
choisit la liberté oui alors écoutez
c'est quelque chose d'assez je vous
prenais quelques exemples que je connais
directement vous avez donc cette famille
là ça c'est quelque chose on va dire
d'assez typique dans le don basse c'est
à dire que le donbas il faut souvenir
qu'avant 2014 vous êtes dans une région
russophone de culture russe où il vous
avez beaucoup de personnes qui se
définissent eux-mêmes comme russe et qui
qui fait que nous avons ces tensions
dans cette zone là de toute façon la
base et après vous avez la génération de
leurs enfants qui souvent vont être plus
eu au fil et qui vont être plus tournés
vers l'ouest
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas si vous
voulez c'est une tension qui existe
depuis très longtemps si vous remontez
dans l'histoire de l'Ukraine vous allez
avoir romedan qui a été juste avant le
conflit dans le don de base où c'était
justement autour de se tourner vers
l'Europe ou se tourner vers la Russie
encore avant ça on peut remonter même à
la Révolution orange de 2004-2005 c'est
quelque chose vous avez ces tensions qui
sont là et qui ont été exacerbées par le
conflit donc vous avez des gens qui sont
tombés d'un côté ou de l'autre si
beaucoup du Kenya ont choisi à cause de
ce qui s'est passé de se mettre à parler
ukrainien plus régulièrement de se
tourner plus clairement vers l'ouest
d'autres finalement sont tombés de
l'autre côté côté est donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui existe qui est
spécifique à la région il faut bien le
comprendre aussi mais par exemple
mon fixer sur la première mission que
j'ai fait s'appelle Alexis sa mère et
criméenne il ne se parle plus elle
habite en Crimée il se téléphone pour
prendre des nouvelles ils ne sont
politiquement pas d'accord il est de
Kiev et les deux Crimée elle est pour
l'opération de Poutine il est contre
c'est quelque chose qui existe Elena
votre réaction à chaud là moi c'est pas
exactement ce que j'ai observé tout au
long de cette guerre du nom base depuis
au début c'est à dire que je n'ai pas
observé de tension entre russophone ou
xénophobe rusophile ukrainophiles etc
c'est davantage par exemple j'ai
découvert le retour à Donetsk en 2012 il
n'y avait pas à ce moment-là de prorus
séparatiste Prusse en fait c'est des
gens qui vivaient dans un pays multi
ethnique multilingue il faut savoir
qu'on Ukraine tout le monde parle russe
tout le monde par l'Ukrainien mais
certaines régions historiquement sont
davantage tournées vers la Russie les
gens dans ces régions là quelque part ne
voyaient pas forcément même
l'affrontière ils avaient de la famille
des deux côtés il la traversée
régulièrement etc mais c'était pas une
vraie tension en fait personne se posait
cette question là et moi ce que j'ai
observé c'est un conflit qui a été
vraiment artificiellement créé à tisé
par la propagande si vous voulez qui a
fait croire à un moment donné après la
révolution proropaine de Madame et après
pendant surtout l'annexion de la Crimée
et le début de la déstabilisation du
don-basse qui a fait croire à ces gens
que en fait les Ukrainiens à Maydan
c'était des nazis qui avait pris le
pouvoir et si on regarde les reportages
de propagande de la télévision russe que
j'ai regardé récemment à partir du 1er
en novembre 2013 dès le début de la
c'était un discours extrêmement violent
extrêmement agressif qui a vraiment à
retourner l'opinion publique de ces
populations en leur faisant croire
qu'ils étaient attaqués agressés c'est
ce qui fait qu'au fil du temps leur
discours s'est radicalisé on entend par
exemple dans le reportage de James qui
est absolument extraordinaire et
excellent il entend ce père commencer sa
phrase en disant l'Ukraine si on peut
encore l'appeler ainsi et c'est ce que
j'entends moi régulièrement tous les
jours dans les émissions
de l'Ukraine etc donc ces discours sont
absolument régurgités ils redisent ils
répètent exactement mot pour mot les
dogmes de la propagande russe ça ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui ça date de 2014 pour
moi c'est un conflit qui est
artificiellement créé par cette propage
général trinquant alors on dit darkmouth
c'est le Verdun
ukrainien est-ce que pour vous ça évoque
effectivement Verdun est-ce que c'est
une bonne référence c'est cette première
guerre mondiale on dit c'est Verdun pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
probablement les les Russes
essentiellement Wagner vont là-bas
quand on veut utiliser l'artillerie pour
gagner du terrain vous avez un groupe
d'infanterie qui avance qui repérant un
objectif qui demande un tir alors si on
est avec des vieilles méthodes un tir de
repérage puis on vous crie efficacité
par 6 et là vous avez quatre pièces qui
tirent 6 obus 6 x 4 24 aubus garantis
que ça nettoie le paysage et ça on
n'entend pas du tout alors ça veut pas
dire que ça n'existe pas mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les tirs sporadique
comme ça c'est vraiment pour rendre la
vie impossible et ça ne veut pas dire
que ça ne tue pas et que ça ne détruit
pas bien sûr dans le reportage de James
alors sur la ligne de front justement
cet effet là il y a aussi on ne sait
beaucoup de gens nous l'ont dit c'est à
dire que il y a une partie de la
population qui quelque part reproche à
l'armée parfois
ukrainien de s'installer à proximité des
bâtiments parce que chaque fois qu'il
voit se déployer une unité militaire et
bien ça tape derrière donc je pense que
aussi qu'il y a un effet psychologique
quelque part de la répétition de ces
frappes c'est-à-dire si vous avez un
camion militaire qui se gare à côté d'un
immeuble boum il y a un obus qui tombe
donc du coup toute la population de
l'immeuble se fasse se tourner vers les
militaires en disant on veut pas qu'ils
soient là parce que s'ils sont là on se
fait taper et ainsi de suite donc ça se
joue aussi à l'échelle de la ville
depuis des semaines et des mois donc ça
c'est quelque chose que les gens vous
disent sur la ligne de front en tout cas
on voit bien ce soldat ukrainien James
qui vous dit il s'est incessant ils sont
toujours là donc on a l'impression qu'il
y a une cavalerie constante en fait de
ces soldats russes qui reviennent qui
reviennent incessamment c'est un peu le
sentiment qu'on a en tout cas en
regardant le reportage bah c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on nous dit c'est ce qu'on
nous a regardé
il y a une véritable concentration c'est
ce qu'on nous a expliqué sur place de
force sur darkmouth c'est un objectif
qui est prioritaire aujourd'hui pour les
Russes is y met énormément de moyens et
d'ailleurs c'était très intéressant de
le voir parce qu'on l'a vu nous ce faire
pendant qu'on était sur place et cette
fortification de la ville le creusement
de ces de ces tranchées en centre-ville
la fabrication enfin tous les jours on
revenait il y avait des grues en ville
qui est en train de s'aller des blocs de
béton de construire des blockhaus de
préparer cette ville pour un combat
urbain intense c'est à dire qu'en tout
cas manifestement l'état-major ukrainien
c'est dit on veut être prêt pour ou si
les Russes rentrent pour leur en faire
baver le plus possible c'est à dire que
l'impression qu'on a c'est qu'il y a un
objectif qui est quelque part côté
ukrainien de tenir la ville et surtout
d'infliger un maximum de pertes aux
Russes qui ont le même objectif
d'ailleurs mais qui eux ne sont pas dans
la ville qui sont à l'extérieur
là-dessus puisqu'ils ont encore ils ont
dit également qu'il y avait des morts il
me semble que c'est aujourd'hui les
Russes donc il reconnaît ce qu'ils ont
quand même des pertes très fortes
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
l'accent sur les pertes ukrainiennes
aussi tous les à la télévision russe
sous-entendez tout le temps nous avons
avancé à soléda et les pertes de
l'ennemi sont énormes sont conséquentes
et cetera quand vous voyez la Russie
parlait de pertes vous voyez des des
portraits de soldats qui défilent par
exemple au journal télévisé tel héros
qui est accompli tel exploit qui a été
décerné post de façon posthume de telle
médailles ça souligne un peu le côté si
vous voulez unique et exclusif de chaque
combattant qui qui meurt au combat c'est
destiné à avoir cette empreinte dans
l'esprit des Russes que chaque
combattant compte pour nous et ils ne
sont que quelques-uns donc ça reste
instrumentalisé même lorsqu'ils
reconnaissent leur père oui oui bien sûr
et encore une fois il souligne bien
davantage les pertes de l'ennemi mais ce
que font du reste aussi d'ailleurs les
Ukrainiens les Ukrainiens qui disent
aujourd'hui qui est plus de 100 000
soldats russes sont morts la façon de
compter c'est dans telle concerne et il
y a telle unité telle unité compte
tendum si on a atteint si on a frappé
tel caserne ça veut dire qu'on a tué
tant de combattants si vous voulez les
chiffres sont instrumentalisés d'un côté
général comment se fait-il que cette
Mahmoud soit devenue effectivement le
symbole de cette guerre qui a une
cristallisation on a encore
effectivement entendu zellens qui
aujourd'hui qui dit on va garder baroute
on va garder soldat alors soldat c'est
un petit village près de barmouth vous
le disiez Jam 70000 habitants alors il y
a des mines de sel à proximité mais
enfin bon est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle a
de stratégie alors je pense que il y a
deux choses à voir du côté russe c'était
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'en fait
c'est essentiellement Wagner qui attaque
c'est la guerre de Monsieur priorgine il
veut démontrer qu'il fait mieux que
l'armée russe je rappelle que l'armée
russe depuis l'été n'a eu aucune
victoire elle a elle s'est retirée de
Kerson elle a été battue à kerkiff
et donc Prigogine veut montrer que
Wagner est capable de faire mieux et il
va tellement loin là-dedans d'ailleurs
qu'il reproche à l'armée russe était sur
telegram il y a dix jours je crois de
pas lui fournir les moyens donc il
envoie mais le problème c'est que Wagner
c'est essentiellement de l'infanterie
mal formé parce que sont des gens qu'on
est allé chercher à droite à gauche on
leur a appris dans les prisons
à servir d'une arme mais c'est pas comme
ça qu'on forme une armée faut un peu
grimper le niveau et donc
il il veut absolument cette victoire et
ce qui se passe actuellement dans la
structure militaire russe et très
intéressante parce que le général sur un
week-end qui commandait et qui a obtenu
le retrait de Carson a donné ce créneau
à Wagner c'est à dire il lui a donné le
créneau or Wagner veut cette victoire
donc il arrive pas à l'avoir à
backmouth donc il vers le Nord pour
aller à soléda et là il annonce une
victoire alors qu'en fait la ville est
pas encore tombée ça veut pas dire
qu'elle va pas tomber prochainement mais
elle n'est pas tombée et là le
kremlindien n'en non non mais attendez
c'est pas encore gagné et on change le
commandement c'est à dire que sur Viking
est rétrogradé on met le chef
d'état-major des armées pour commander
ça ça veut dire d'une certaine façon
des officiers intérieure à la Russie
c'est-à-dire le président Poutine a à sa
botte si je veux dire shoy goût et le
chef d'état-major des armées ça ce sont
les valeurs sûres sur en Viking et prix
gaugine ce sont pas des valeurs sûres
parce que il roule pour eux mais
pourtant sur le week-end avait été nommé
par Poutine pour changer la stratégie au
moment où je pense qu'il a eu le tort de
donner un créneau à Wagner et que Wagner
peut ainsi faire sa pub si j'ose dire
sur la victoire prochaine qu'il va avoir
il faut se souvenir qu'au moment où
personne a été évacué
il y a eu beaucoup de critiques le seul
qui a plus d'oeil c'est Wagner pris
d'origine qui a applaudi la décision de
thyroïkine donc on voit bien ce lien et
cette espèce de hiérarchie parallèle qui
s'est mise en place et donc sa pose
problème et l'armée russe veut
aujourd'hui se réorganiser préparer des
grandes offensives parce que quand on
regarde ce qui est en train de se passer
pardonnez-moi c'est très et votre
portage est super mais on regarde au
microscope parce que sur l'ensemble du
front il y a que cet endroit qui bouge
ailleurs ça ne bouge pas et donc les
Russes eux préparent autre chose de plus
grande ampleur de même que les
Ukrainiens préparent quelque chose de
plus grande ampleur donc voilà ce qui se
passe en ce moment dans cette région
sur barthout James est-ce qu'il vous
parle des forces de Wagner parce que là
il disait on a ils sont nombreux ils
sont nombreux ces soldats russes est-ce
qu'ils disent les Ukrainiens qui s'agit
des forces de Wagner
milice privé tout de même et d'ailleurs
il me semble-t-il n'est même pas reconnu
en Russie il me semble qu'elle est même
interdite en Russie donc non le en fait
j'ai posé la question bien sûr au soldat
qu'on a pu rencontrer et en fait ils ne
font pas de différence en réalité c'est
à dire quand vous leur posez la question
pour eux c'est simplement des combats
des combattants russes je pense qu'ils
ne font pas la différence entre l'armée
russe Wagner les combattants de la DNR
etc tout ça pour eux ce sont ces ennemi
ce sont les orques en fait c'est
vraiment ça le le message c'est ce sont
les orques et par contre ce qu'ils
disent effectivement c'est que il y a
des vagues de de combattants enfin ce
que ce que raconte ce soldat dans le
reportage d'ailleurs et voilà c'est il
ça n'arrête jamais ça continue
lui-même a dit que c'était une boucherie
non c'est un abattoir pardon le terme
employé c'est un abattoir c'est-à-dire
que lui-même reconnaît qu'il envoie
c'est c'est soldats dans l'abattoir à la
chair à canon et comme ils sont très mal
formés ils y vont puis alors je sais pas
dans quel état si il y a eu des
expressions on sait que l'alcool circule
pas mal dans l'armée russe et ce sont
des gens que bon une bonne partie qui
ont été recrutés en prison parce que
ceux qui ont été les à l'origine Wagner
c'était des anciens des forces spéciales
qui basculaient sur un contrat privé
mais cela ils sont morts et donc on rend
on remboule on remet en permanence des
gens qui sortent de prison et Léna c'est
spécificité de Wagner ça justement on
est pris goji en fait il a un agenda
politique aussi peut-être qu'il faut en
parler alors là il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire d'abord au sein de Wagner
effectivement vous avez plusieurs
hiérarchies vous avez d'abord les vrais
combattants aguerris les pures ils sont
ils sont morts
enfin pas tous peut-être d'ailleurs mais
qui ont des fonctions très certainement
plus élevées y compris celles d'exécuter
ceux qui sont tout en bas les
prisonniers qui chercheraient à déserter
ou à fuir ce qui a été fait dans cette
terrible vidéo qui a circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux effectivement pris goji
alors selon le renseignement américain a
recruté 40000 prisonniers le chiffre
paraît plausible au vu de toutes les
informations qu'on a pu recueillir mais
effectivement il y a toute cette chair à
canon qui qui combat dans les dans les
rangs Wagner ensuite au niveau de
l'organisation des forces de combat il y
a énormément de factions qui combattent
côté russe il y a celles qu'on a tous à
l'oreille c'est-à-dire Wagner il y a
l'armée régulière et entre les deux il y
a un certain nombre de formations de
bataillon plus ou moins mercenaires plus
ou moins bon bénévoles plus peut-être
plus maintenant sans doute des
mercenaires y compris les armées dit
corpus 1 et corpus 2 des républiques
populaires autoproclamés de l'ADNr LNR
qui vient d'être annexée par la Russie
etc je sais très bien on est extrêmement
opaque depuis le 24 février 2022 donc
moi je ne peux l'analyser qu'à travers
le prisme de ce que j'ai pu observer à
l'échelle locale dans le don-basse lors
d'opération auquel a participé l'armée
russe à savoir le fameux aéroport de
Donetsk les batailles de débats CV et
dit le vice qu'à ce moment là et aussi
des échos que j'ai eu de mes contacts
mercenaires au début de la guerre et
apparemment à la base personne ne peut
agir sans la coordination et l'aval du
ministère russe de la Défense
c'est-à-dire que Prigogine ne peut pas
lui-même décider d'aller prendre
autonome donc
a priori de comment j'analyse la
situation il ne peut pas le faire et
d'ailleurs c'est pour cela sans doute
que il a ils ont fait cette vidéo que
Prigogine a adoubé en quelque sorte les
combattants Wagner en disant le guerre à
simov vous êtes un pardonnez-moi
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit dans la vidéo ça
c'est du jamais vu que quelqu'un
s'adresse au chef d'état-major des
armées de cette façon mais de ne pas
nous fournir d'armes de munitions pour
qu'on aille se battre donc ça quelque
part ça aussi
confiant la version du fait que cela a
été confié à Wagner maintenant ce sont
des gens qui se mettent extrêmement en
scène ce sont eux qui font des vidéos ce
sont eux qui les font circuler l'armée
russe ils font pas ça donc est-ce que à
darkmouth il n'y a que Wagner moi ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup je pense que c'est
une opération coordonnée avec l'armée
régulière russe les Wagner sont en avant
ils se mettent en scène un peu trop sans
doute ils disent avoir pris la ville
alors qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait ou les
villes de Mahmoud et de Solidar qui sont
les verrous stratégiques sur les
frontières de denietz qu'avec ramator ce
qui se l'audience qu'à la clé mais je
pense que tout ceci est coordonné après
au sein de cette guerre et de ce conflit
au bout d'un moment ça déra les les
chefs il y a des luttes de clan il y en
a beaucoup du pouvoir c'est ce qui se
passe avec Prigogine et il commence à
tirer la bourre tous les uns avec les
autres on l'a observé dans le bombasse
localement beaucoup beaucoup
sur la logistique de l'armée russe en
tout cas habituellement enfin on les a
vu opérer un peu partout les Wagner il
s'appuie
surface fonctionner tout seul déjà à la
base mais il semblerait que ce qu'il
soit passé aussi c'est que Prigogine
soit aller un petit peu loin dans sa com
et voulu s'attribuer un petit peu trop
d'importance et peut-être aussi un peu
au passage dénigrer l'armée russe qui
finalement quand on a la communication
actuelle de prix gaugine c'est nous
faisons tout l'armée russe ne fait rien
et on sait pas ce qu'il fabrique ils
sont incompétents et regardez comme on
est fort ce qui est au bout d'un moment
va irriter l'état-majorie dans ces
cas-là bah si c'est ce qui vient de se
passer c'est ce qui vient de se passer
c'est il sait faire cadrer je vais dire
quand vous avez le porte-parole de enfin
quand vous avez Dimitri pescov qui qui
qui dit c'est pas vrai la vie n'est pas
tombée vous êtes en train de d'infiger
un camouflet aujourd'hui hommage
il y a vraiment en fait justement que
oui mais il y a vraiment une remise en
ordre de la hiérarchie militaire
serrurerie le commandant qui commandait
qui donc a donné ce créneau et dans
lequel combat Wagner a été rétrogradé
c'est clair
guirassimov a été pris mis en charge et
ce tenez-vous bien celui qui est à
l'origine de la débandade de kerkiff a
été promu chef d'état-major de l'armée
de terre donc ça veut bien dire que le
président Poutine
sur des fidèles et par ces fidèles il
veut réorganiser le système pour ne pas
avoir effectivement les excès qu'on voit
les batailles de clan et puis c'est vrai
que privé au bout du compte c'est un
voyou qui est en prison qui a réussi
grand grandes réussites à être cuisinier
de Poutine et par là qui a grimpé et
aujourd'hui
excusez-moi de l'expression mais il a
peut-être un peu le melon et il
s'imagine peut-être que il peut tout
faire et là je pense que d'une certaine
façon Poutine le recadrer un peu
indirectement mais le rocade quand même
pour revenir sur le front ils ont le
moral ces soldats Ukrainiens malgré tout
il continue à se battre à aucun vous
n'avez pas rencontré il y a pas de
détection vraiment il y a pas c'est
toujours très difficile à dire ce qui ce
qu'on a vu effectivement au moment où on
est sur place sont effectivement
on le moral enfin voilà ça c'est c'est
mais après vous dire que tout le monde
est extrêmement motivé mobilisé c'est
impossible à savoir
mais ce qu'on a vu par contre
effectivement quand on voit par contre
la casse aussi qu'il peut y avoir côté
craignait qui est bien réel quand on l'a
vu dans cette nouvelle
vous disiez quoi une centaine de blessés
par jour dans cet hôpital sachant que
dans la région en fait comment ça
fonctionne vous avez des points
d'extraction près de près du front qui
emmène tous les soldats blessés donc à
un point qui est on va dire ce qu'ils
appellent le point de stabilisation qui
est à l'intérieur de Dortmund où on
prend les blessés et on les stabilise
c'est ça c'est-à-dire et après on les
évacue et on les évacue vers les
hôpitaux vers tous les hôpitaux qui se
trouvent dans ce secteur et ce l'hôpital
où on a tourné je dirais pas où il était
mais celui-là c'en est un de toute une
série qui sont en deuxième rideau qui
reçoivent les blessés qui traitent ceux
qui peuvent traiter et ceux qui sont
trop grièvement blessés on les évacue
ensuite sur ni pro qui là pour le coup
est une grande ville avec des
infrastructures hein
c'est-à-dire qu'on est plus dans le
système des c'est mais c'est pas non
plus complètement de la médecine de
guerre comme elle peut être pratiquée à
l'intérieur de darkmouth pour stabiliser
le patient avant de de l'exfiltrer vers
les vrais hôpitaux Helena ce que vous
pensez qu'il va y avoir effectivement en
parler d'une offensive avant le 24
février cette fameuse date anniversaire
offensive
ukrainienne offensive russe de
envergure tout à fait possible c'est il
y a des signaux qui le montrent en effet
après le problème c'est que les
Ukrainiens d'abord sont extrêmement
discrets sur les stratégie militaire et
montre très peu de ce qu'ils font
réellement on l'a vu avec cette
contre-offensive spectaculaire début
septembre sur kerkiff ou en fait tout le
monde a été pris de cours y compris les
journalistes Ukrainiens parce que les
Ukrainiens sont efficaces aussi parce
que ils contrôlent extrêmement leur
communication côté russe je le disais à
l'instant c'est totalement opaque donc
voilà on en est déduit à des analyses à
des stratégie militaire si vous voulez
des uns et des autres elle est
difficilement prévisible mais services
renseignement américain il me semble
disait qu'il y aurait peut-être une
offensive russe importante ou ce sont
les services renseignements
Ukrainiens qui le disaient généralement
deux critères importants
avoir réuni les forces et avoir la météo
on l'oublie trop souvent la météo
favorable le problème c'est que la météo
est trop douce et que il fait très froid
aujourd'hui moins 15 mais dimanche ça
monte au dessus de 0 et donc ça veut
dire que le sol va pas être ferme et
donc les blindés qui sont nécessaires
pour une offensive sont difficilement
utilisables et moi je crois plus
volontiers que les Ukraine les Russes
pardon ont besoin de temps avec la
mobilisation l'équipement pour reformer
des unités pour être capable de partir à
l'offensive pour ça que je pense pas
pour les pour les vous savez les Russes
le temps n'a pas la même notion que chez
nous et je pense que c'est l'été qu'il
vise et non pas l'automne ou le
printemps les Ukrainiens en revanche ont
intérêt eux à monter une offensive avant
pour taper avant que les Russes soient
prêts mais le problème c'est que la
météo est pas très favorable malgré le
fait qu'il soit très armé aujourd'hui
que on dit d'ailleurs qu'ils ont des
armées les plus modernes d'Europe
aujourd'hui c'est très bien ils sont ils
sont bien armés mais tout ce qu'on
annonce n'est toujours pas arrivé
les patriotes c'est dans 6 mois les
blindés c'est dans deux mois voilà donc
si vous voulez entre ce qu'on entend
comme annonce je rappelle que la réunion
de Rammstein c'est la semaine prochaine
où on va probablement dire oui des
blindés et les blindés quand bah dans un
mois dans un mois et demi bon ça va être
probablement le début de du printemps
début du printemps les blindés ça
fonctionne pas bien il y a beaucoup de
bout donc c'est un petit peu compliqué
et vous avez raison et ils ont raison
d'ailleurs d'être très secret sur leur
stratégie souvenez-vous attaque personne
attaque car kiff personne avait vu venir
l'attaque un quartier et c'est comme ça
que ça n'a fonctionné James avant le 24
février vous le sentez comment si je
puis dire c'est très difficile à dire
honnêtement c'est très difficile à dire
c'est dans un mois oui il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses voilà on peut
craindre effectivement des frappes en
profondeur avec des missiles de
croisière des choses comme ça ça c'est
probable malheureusement mais bon c'est
c'est impossible à dire en effet c'est
vrai que moi je suis je suis assez
d'accord je pense qu'on pourrait avoir
une surprise
ukrainien avec potentiellement une
offensive mais laquelle où c'est
difficile à dire mais en attendant peut
tomber et si effectivement c'est une
victoire russe barthout ou là ça sera un
tournant véritable en tout cas il le
présente comme ça c'est à dire que c'est
c'est oui le présente comme ça comme
chaque ville qui après non c'est pas
c'est pas un tournant comme a pu l'être
la région de kerkiff qui sont perdus
d'ailleurs ou Liman ou ce genre de
d'endroits si vous laissez c'est plus
des verrous encore une fois stratégiques
sur la route qui va encore être très
longue jusqu'au ville de cramator ce qui
depuis le début de la guerre en 2014 et
le siège de l'état-major ukrainien et la
ville de sloviance qui est extrêmement
symbolique aussi pour les Russes puisque
c'est la première ville que qu'ils
avaient occupé en 2014 donc ça c'est
vraiment les objectifs c'est ce que
disait Vladimir Poutine au début de la
guerre c'est finalement on veut
restaurer la république populaire de
Donetsk et celle de l'ougance dans ses
frontières AD tentatives qui ont été
inscrites dans la constitution des
républiques autoproclamés au moment où
elles ont fait sécession de l'Ukraine
donc effectivement ce sont les objectifs
mais bon évidemment dans le contexte
actuel et avec les difficultés que
rencontre l'armée russe n'importe quel
prise comme ça en fait c'est important
ils veulent besoin d'une victoirement je
répète une victoire pour Wagner aussi
pour Monsieur Prigogine mais une
victoire russe c'est sûr qu'il y en a
pas eu depuis un petit moment donc ça
sera médiatiquement très important
maintenant il faut avoir la capacité
d'exploiter cette victoire et là je mets
beaucoup de points d'interrogation sur
la capacité aujourd'hui pour l'armée
russe d'exploiter une victoire si
la ville de
tomber
le Chine le documentaire enfin le
reportage documentaire donc de James
James André merci d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau que vous avez réalisé
avec Maïssa Awad survivre à barmoud vous
pouvez le retrouver dans cette émission
bien sûr qu'on retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi sur www.france24 sur
notre site Internet et puis surtout les
réseaux sociaux reportage donc survivre
à barpood merci de nous avoir suivi pour
rester avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]